[Music]
dopamine is a chemical substance that
serves to send messages between two
cells in the brain and that's we call
neurotransmitters
there are many neurotransmitters and
dopamine plays a key role in modulating
the areas of the brain that enable a
wide variety of functions best known is
movement and when your dopamine cells
die for example you cannot initiate
movement and that's Parkinson disease
but the effects of dopamine go way
beyond movement and one of the actions
very relevant for drug abuse and
addiction is it modulates the areas of
the brain involved with our ability to
perceive reward
reinforcement and to be motivated by
that reward to do actions so for example
it's so important that if you can
generate through trans trans genetic
genetic technologies you can generate an
A Mize that does not produce synthetize
dopamine these animals will die of
starvation because they don't have the
motivation to engage in the behaviors to
go and eat the food you can rescue this
animals by injecting them dopamine into
the areas of the brain that control
these but if you don't do that these
animals will die of starvation and that
really epitomizes how extraordinary
important dopamine is it gives you that
energy that drive to do things now drugs
of abuse we know that for the past 15
years all of them whether it's legal or
illegal they don't make any distinctions
over there in terms of the pharmacology
they increase dopamine in specific areas
of the brain of the limbic brain and
this ability to increase dopamine when a
person takes that role is associated
directly with it's what we call
rewarding or reinforcing effects so if
you can actually manipulate it in such a
way that you interfere with the ability
of a drugged increase dopamine then that
drug is no longer pleasurable and so
that's that's why dopamine is so
important visibly understanding why
certain drugs can produce addiction and
others not if a drug produces in
is in dopamine in these limbic areas of
the brain then your brain is going to
understand that signal as something that
is very reinforcing and we'll learn it
very rapidly and so that the next time
you get exposed to that stimuli your
brain already has learned that that's
reinforcing and you immediately what we
call the type of memory that's
conditioning will desire that particular
drop now these mechanisms are not
developing our brains to take drugs
these mechanisms of dopamine signaling
reinforcements and once you have
experienced it getting conditioned to it
it's extraordinary important way for
nature to ensure that humans as well as
animals will perform behaviors that are
indispensable for survival so therefore
it shouldn't surprise us that behavior
such as eating or sexual behavior are
linked with increases in dopamine and
and in the same areas that drugs do it
there are differences though because
natural reinforcers increased dopamine
as a function very much of the context
what do I mean by that if you are hungry
for example and you get exposed to food
that will increase dopamine much more
that if you just finished eating and so
as you eat the ability of food to
increase dopamine goes down and
eventually disappears and because it
disappears you are no longer motivated
to eat the food
what happens with drunk though on the
other hand is they do not decline the
ability to increase dopamine so a person
may take heat of cocaine snorted it
increases dopamine takes a second it
increases dopamine third four five six
so there's never that decrease that
ultimately leads to the satiety and this
is believed that then these differences
between the normal responses of the
dopamine stimuli as it was developed
through evolution to serve physiological
functions versus the ways that drugs do
it much more potently longer duration of
action and it does not decline with
repeated administration is believed to
trigger the adaptations the plastic
changes in our brain that eventually
will lead in those individuals that are
vulnerable to addiction to the process
of addiction which is a condition where
upon the person with repeated
administration of drugs no longer can
control his or her ability to decide
when they take or they don't take the
drug it's fundamentally a stage where
that individual has lost control and has
the intense drive to compulsively take
the drug and that's what we call
addiction not everybody that takes drugs
actually becomes addicted we come to
recognize for example that approximately
50 percent of the vulnerability of a
person to take to become addicted is
some genetically determined
so that vulnerability has a very strong
genetic component it also has other
processes that determine vulnerabilities
for example if you can expose to drugs
when you're very young very early
adolescence they're much more likely to
become addicted that if you get exposed
to the same drugs when you are an adult
and this has to do with the fact that
the adolescent brain is much more
neuroplastic than the adult brain and as
a result of that a draw which triggers
this adaptation process is likely to
produce
this changes faster in an adolescent and
it's also the duration of those changes
is likely to be much longer lasting in
an adolescent than it is in an adult so
these are our two processes as it
relates to addiction
[Music]